the point negative 8 comma 5 is
reflected across the y-axis plot
negative 8 comma 5 and its reflection
across the y-axis so first let's plot
negative 8 comma 5 so its x-coordinate
is negative 8 so I'll just use this one
right over here so the x-coordinate is
negative 8 and the y-coordinate is 5 so
I'll go up 5 so the y-coordinate is 5
right over here you see negative 8 and 5
we've gone 8 to the left because it's
negative and then we've gone 5 up
because it's a positive 5 so we've
plotted negative 8 comma 5 now we have
to plot its reflection across the y-axis
the y axis and so you can imagine if
this was some type of for the some type
of lake or something and you were to see
its reflection and this is say like the
moon you would see its reflection
roughly around here you would see an
equal distance away from the y axis so
you would see it at 8 to the right of
the y axis which would be at positive 8
and still fought at a and still 5 above
the x axis so that's its reflection
right over here this reflection is the
point 8 comma 5 let's do a couple more
of these the point negative 6 comma
negative 7 is reflect this should say
reflected across the x axis plot
negative 6 comma negative 7 and its
reflection across the x axis so negative
6 comma negative 7 so we're going to go
6 to the left of the origin and we're
going to go 6 below and we're going to
go down 7 so there we go negative 6
comma negative 7 is right there and we
are reflecting across the x axis so once
again if you imagine that this is some
type of a lake or maybe some type of an
upside-down lake or a mirror where would
we think we see its reflection well its
reflection would be the same distance
we're reflecting across the x axis so
it'd be the same distance but now above
the x axis so this was 7 below now we're
going to go 7 below above the x axis
it's going to be at the same
x-coordinate
there you have it right over here we
reflected this point to right up here
because we reflected across the x-axis
let's check our answer let's do one more
the point B the point B is a reflection
of point A across which axis so let's
think about this right over here this is
at the point negative 6 comma 5 this is
at the point negative 5 comma 6 so let's
see it doesn't look like it's only one
axis if I were to reflect this point
across the y-axis it would go all the
way to positive 6 5 so it would go all
the way right over here so if I reflect
a just across the y-axis it would go
there and then if I reflected that point
across the x-axis then I would go I
would end up at 5 below the x-axis at an
x coordinate of 6 so to go from A to B
you could reflect across the Y and then
the X or you could reflect across the X
and get you right over here it would get
you to negative 6 comma 5 and then
reflect across the Y so it's really
reflecting across both axes so we would
reflect across the x-axis and then the
y-axis it would have also been
legitimate if we said the Y axis and
then the x axis let's check our answer
we got it right